مكان وجود الجنرلين المتقاتلين في السودان
يثير تساؤلات كثيره رغم الانباء الوارده
من الجانبين فلا دليل قاطعا على مكان
البرهان ولا تاكيد مطلقا لمكان حميدتي
رفيقارب بالامس وعدوها اليوم لم يظهر
ميدانيا منذ بدايه المعارك في ساحه القتال
المعلومات الصادره عن اعلام الطرفين بحسب
الشرق الاوسط تشير الى وجود القاده
العسكريين للقوتين في المقر الرئيسي
للقياده العامه للجيش وسط العاصمه اي في
المحيط ذاته قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد
انه يتولى مهامه ولن يبرح مكانه قائلا انه
يدافع عن السودان
هذه مهنتي وهذا شرفي
الا محمولا على نع
قبل ذلك البرهان ظهر في اليوم الثاني من
الاشتباكات في مقطع فيديو لمده ثوان قليله
داخل غرفه الى جانبه قاده عسكريون اما
ظهوره الثاني فكان يوم العيد في خطاب مسجل
صوتا وصوره توجه فيه بالتهنئه للشعب
السوداني
الترجيحات تقول ان الغرفه قد تكون ملجا
مخصصا للعمليه السريه في احدى الوحدات
العسكريه التابعه للجيش في مقر القياده
العامه او اي منطقه عسكريه في العاصمه او
خارجها
اما قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
فمنذ بدء العمليات العسكريه لم يظهر على
الاطلاق غير انه اكد في مقابله عبر الهاتف
مع العربيه انه يقود المعارك العسكريه مع
قواته على الارض بنفسه
مراقبون يرون ان قاده الدعم السريع
يتخوفون من سيطره قاده الجيش على اجهزه
الاتصالات وان ظهورهم او اتصالاتهم عبر
الشبكات تسهل تحديد اماكن وجودهم
فكيف ستنتهي قصه الزعيم ونائبه في بلد بدا
يتحول معماره الى عصف ماكول جراء دراوه
المعارك بلال الوجداني العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات